[Music]  [Music]  okay  got eyes on the bar  yep  here he comes  and i got the dealer  [Music]  nina they're heading your way  they're here you should have eyes on the  merchandise  i sure do  [Music]  was that a gunshot  ah they shot the dealer  that is so unprofessional  yeah let's do it great whenever you're  ready kevin what are you guys thinking  for dinner tonight how about my whole  famous chili con carne  [Music]  hey guys what you got in the  oh  stolen marshall mdi-101 m9 multi-rocket  shoulder launchers nice  my buddies and i have been looking all  over town from us have you been hoarding  see we need them for our startup it's a  criminal empire  after um  [Music]  [Music]  one two three four five six seven eight  nine  [Music]  you should buckle up  ugh  [Music]  get the [ __ ] away from my friends  [Music]  so  you